[Music]
what do the netherlands really look like
to get a better sense of proportion
let's go on a 100 second walk across the
nation
each second of the walk reveals one
percent of the lands and how they look
from above
are you ready for the netherlands in 100
seconds
[Music]
we walk through 18 kinds of land that
have gone in a blink
coastal mud flats occupy five percent of
the netherlands and five seconds of our
walk
we spent eight seconds listening to
birds and walking in large woodlands
the houses and gardens of villages towns
and cities
cover eight percent of the country
[Music]
and now we're in the deep for 12 seconds
it's time to wade and swim we're
crossing freshwater lakes
the rest of the land is used for farms
we walk for 12 seconds
through a complex patchwork of small
fields used for crops
and cows as well as occasional houses
for people
pigs and chickens we spend 18 seconds
walking through larger fields of crops
most is fed to livestock we pass through
maize
wheat
potatoes
[Music]
sugar beet vegetables
and flowers
our last 24 and 24 seconds
takes us through pastures this the
single biggest use of land
is mostly used for feeding and rearing
cows
in all at a time when a third of dutch
species are at risk of extinction
do we need to rethink this mix of lands
we have and how we use them
i need more trees please i think more
balance would be better
so what if we made more space for nature
[Music]
you